COMMANDER BEAUJOLAIS!
OUR FORCES
HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED.
THE ENEMY IS AT THE EDGE
OF THE VILLAGE.
THERE ARE NOT
MANY OF US LEFT.
SHOULD WE SURRENDER?
- YOU MAY SURRENDER, JENGO.
BUT I AM AFRAID THAT IS
A LUXURY I CANNOT AFFORD.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT THEY DO TO WARLORDS.
IF THEY CAPTURE ME,
THEY WILL TORTURE ME FOR WEEKS.
THAT IS NO WAY TO GO.
I WANT YOU, MY MOST TRUSTED
SOLDIER OVER THE AGE OF EIGHT,
TO TAKE MY LIFE.
THAT IS MY FINAL ORDER.
AAH!
OH! OH! OH! OW!
OW! NO, DO--NO!
AAH, STOP, STOP!
WHAT THE HELL ARE YOU DOING?
HAA!
- I WAS TRYING
TO KILL YOU, SIR.
- NOT WITH THIS!
THERE'S A GUN IN THE DRAWER!
AAH!
- OH.
SO SORRY. OKAY.
- AMAZING.
YOU MISSED EVERY
VITAL ORGAN, JENGO.
OH...
- FOUND IT.
- ALL RIGHT,
NOW KILL ME, JENGO.
HURRY, PLEASE!
[screams]
NOT IN THE KNEE!
- I THOUGHT YOU MIGHT
WANT AN OPEN CASKET.
- YOU ARE AN IDIOT!
[groans]
- DON'T SAY THAT.
I DID TRY MY BEST.
- SHOOT ME IN THE HEAD,
YOU IMBECILE!
[groans]
GOD.
- GOOD-BYE, COMMANDER.
[cocks gun]
YOU SORRY-ASS PIECE OF SH--
[gun clicks]
[clicking]
- DID YOU JUST INSULT ME
AS YOU WERE ABOUT TO FIRE?
- OH, WELL,
YOU HAD INSULTED ME EARLIER.
I TH--I THOUGHT
YOU WOULD BE DEAD.
AH, OOH. SO SORRY.
- OW!
OW! OW! OW!
STOP--STOP IT!
WHAT THE HELL ARE YOU DOING?
- THE GUN IS EMPTY.
WOULD YOU LIKE I STAB YOU AGAIN?
- NO, NO, NO! PLEASE!
JENGO, THERE ARE BULLETS!
THEY ARE OVER THERE!
- OKAY.
- JENGO, PLEASE HURRY!
I AM IN AGONY!
[clatters]
OW!
WHAT THE BLAZES, MAN?
- I THOUGHT
I COULD KILL YOU VERY QUICK
BY HITTING YOU
WITH THAT BIG COOKING POT.
- OH, MY GOD, WOULD YOU PLEASE,
I MEAN, PLEASE GET IT OVER WITH?
- I DID NOT
FIND THE BULLETS.
- WHAT?
- BUT BETTER.
BOILING HOT WATER.
- WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO WITH--
[screams]
I SURRENDER!
I AM THE GENERAL
DOMINICK BUJUNE!
- COMMANDER! DON'T GO!
THEY'LL TORTURE YOU!